- And everyone, hi.
As Ben just said,
I'm your warm up act.
Hi.
I'm Alyssa Goodman.
I'm one of the co-directors
at Radcliffe Institute
for Science.
I'm also a professor in
the Astronomy Department
and on the Steering Committee
of the Science Initiative
here at Harvard.
And those organizations--
not counting
the astronomy department--
are bringing you along
with the Institute for Advanced
Computational Science, two
talks by Ben Schneiderman here
at Harvard, today and tomorrow.
So you're at the first one.
Hopefully you're
at the right talk.
And tomorrow you're
welcome to join
for the second
one, which I think
is in the geological classroom.
The information is right up
there, as well as the topic.
But what I'm going
to do is first--
I'm just curious.
Before you tell me
anything about Ben,
Ben and I are both
curious who's here.
So if you are considering
yourself a computer scientist
or that your first field or
interest is computer science,
can you raise your hand?
Thank you.
If you're from industry,
can you raise your hand?
A few people.
Thank you.
If you're from Harvard,
can you raise your hand?
OK.
If you're from not Harvard,
can you raise your hand?
OK, Ben.
You know their favorite color?
What else want to know?
- I want to know [INAUDIBLE].
- Ah.
If you're very interested
in design, raise your hand.
OK, excellent.
And what about the humanities?
Any actual humanists?
Wonderful, OK.
Library people?
Ah, there we go.
Thank you, James.
I know his name.
So he'd like social
scientists next.
OK.
Wait.
Why are you so hesitant
to raise your hand
when you're a social scientist?
It's like ooh, it's our fault
if this AI stuff goes wrong.
Anyway, so let me just tell
you a little bit about Ben--
unless we really do need to
know their favorite color.
No?
No, Ben?
OK.
So probably most of you have
heard of Ben, or Ben's work.
And you should be
very grateful to him
every time you use your iPhone
or tag someone in a photo.
And maybe he'll explain
some of his work
today in the more
design usability
aspects of the interaction
between humans and computers,
which is what Ben has been
interested in pretty much
for most of his career.
He actually started
out-- right now
he's a distinguished university
professor at the University
of Maryland.
And he started something there--
the Human Computer
Interaction Lab
there at the mercy of
Maryland-- something
like 40 some odd years ago.
35 years ago.
But before that, he actually
was trained originally
as an undergraduate in physics.
I love the fact that he
also went to Bronx Science,
because I'm originally
From New York, too.
So for anybody here,
I should have said
who here went to Bronx Science?
Anybody?
Oh, come on.
There's usually at least one.
OK.
But he did go to City College,
where my dad also went.
OK, we got a City
College person.
Excellent.
OK.
So we went to City College and
then he went to Stony Brook.
After getting his bachelor's
in physics at City College
he got a PhD in
computer science.
And then he says he
sort of became 20%
a psychologist, because
he became more interested
in not just what
computers could do
but what humans and
computers do together, where
humans use computers as tools.
- There you go.
Right.
- Don't say that humans
and computers are
partners when you're with Ben.
This is just a bad idea.
If you try it in the
questions, you'll see why.
OK.
So anyway, so Ben has done
many, many things in his career
that led to important
technologies
that you use in
your everyday life,
including hypertext, touch
screen computing, tree maps,
and other kinds
of visualization--
the names of which
you might not know.
But Ben and his
colleagues are responsible
for them making your lives
navigating lots of information
through computers much easier.
Tomorrow he's going to talk
about event flow, which
is one of the technologies
he's worked on more recently.
And some of you may
know about NodeXL, which
is a graph visualization tool.
But today he's not going
to talk about any of that,
I don't think, or a little bit.
And so I'm just got to
say one more thing, which
is Ben has these rules about
human and computer interaction
usually applied to
visualization-- information
visualization.
And I just picked
out one that I want
to read to you so
that you can keep it
in mind as you hear Ben speak.
And you'll see the
connection between design
and human computer interaction
design and his thoughts
about artificial intelligence
and machine learning.
And so rule number seven from
his famous book, "Designing
the User Interface"," which
first came out in 1986 and is
in its sixth edition now,
says, "Support internal locus
of control," and
then that's explained
as experienced
operators strongly
desire the sense they are
in charge of the system,
and that the system
responds to their actions.
Design the system to make
users the initiators of actions
rather than the responders.
So I think we'll
learn today what
that means in the context
of artificial intelligence,
and we'll also learn why
an important quote from Ben
is that machine learning
without visualization
should be illegal.
So we'll find out
what that means.
And thank you very
much coming, Ben.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you for that
nice introduction.
And you gave half my talk,
so we can move it along.
I'm very pleased
to be here and once
we get my slides we will be--
that's not what we want.
Yup.
You want to try that again?
All right.
I'll try it that way.
OK.
No slide viewer,
straight up slides.
Good afternoon.
I'm very pleased to be here.
I've had an
energizing day talking
with students and
Radcliffe Fellows
and visiting around the campus.
And I'm ready now for a spirited
discussion with you here today.
So Alissa's already
said I'm happy to be
from the University of
Maryland and represent
the 35-year-old Human Computer
Interaction Lab, which
is a [INAUDIBLE] bunch
between computer science
and the College of Information
Studies, rapidly growing
known as the iSchool.
But also we work with
other groups on campus,
including the wonderfully
titled Maryland Institute
for Technology and
the Humanities, MITH.
There are about
1,000 tech reports
on our web site, 200 videos,
200 project reports and so on.
So you can take a
look about that group.
Alissa's already
mentioned the book,
"Designing the User Interface."
that's been my calling card.
I hope some of you have
seen it or used it.
And it covers some of the key
things and direct manipulation
theories and the way to
design screens and menus
and search systems, social
media visualization.
And Alissa was kind enough to
mention the eight golden rules.
I was pressured
to reduce the 500
rules that were in these
large books and handbooks.
And it was useful 'cause
it forced me to think
at a little higher level.
And so there were things
like strive for consistency,
and prevent errors,
and the one you said,
which was from an earlier
version of that book--
which was asserting
internal locus of control.
I sort of updated it in the
latest version to just simply--
the locus of control
phrase confused people,
and so I just focused about
assuring the users in control.
And you'll see that's going
to come back in the story,
as well.
Just where I come
from, as Alissa
described, from background
doing database and file design
optimizations and working
my way towards psychology.
In 1980 I wrote the book
called "Software Psychology"
and tried to bring these
disciplines closer together.
And along the way the kind
of-- some design things
travel really well.
The idea of links,
that certain words that
are highlighted in
the sentence-- and we
chose light blue because
we studied a dozen versions
and we had all
kinds of research.
And bright red was
more visible, but it
undermined people's
comprehension and retention
of the text they were reading.
So blue turned out to be good.
Tim Berners-Lee said oh, yeah.
That looks good.
And he cited our
work in his manifesto
for the web in spring '89.
So those things
traveled really well.
The touch screen
keyboard-- early on we
had done a nine inch wide
keyboard inch square buttons.
And we did seven and five and
three, and we studied them.
And yes, it does take a
little longer on a three inch
wide keyboard, but
people could do it.
Now the reviewers of the
paper didn't believe it.
And it took a video
to convince them
that it was really possible.
And the strategy was to put
your finger on the screen,
give a little cursor
just above your finger,
and then be able
to move it around.
And that's still what
resides on your iPhone.
We call that the lift off
strategy, and Steve Jobs--
I was a consultant for Apple,
and Steve Jobs visited our lab.
So there again, I see the path
for those things to happen.
And things like photo
tagging, we did.
And we got a patent for that,
and that's traveled well also.
So those are easy stories
to tell a cocktail parties.
Some of the more
difficult things,
which I'm proud of as well--
a Spotfire tool that came from
our work, which had the early
ideas of multiple windows,
dynamic query sliders
to control ranges,
rapid incremental and reversible
updates, brushing and linking--
a lot of those ideas came from
the early developments there.
There's the Treemaps in a
financial , tool FinViz,
a commercial one where it shows
all the stocks in this S&P 500.
The green stocks are rising,
the red stocks are falling.
The area indicates the
market capitalization.
And so you can see Apple
is the biggest one.
And there's Google and
Facebook and ExxonMobil
and whatever-- all these
other different groups.
And it's a pretty good
day in this example here,
but there are some red ones.
And you can see as a field the
utility sector is doing poorly.
And often that sector travels
in the opposite direction
of the general stock market.
NodeXL was a network
visualization tool
with 600,000 downloads.
And we're working on the
second edition of that book.
And this was an early--
on the first visualization of
the polarization in Congress.
These were the red Republicans.
I've lost my cursor.
Come on.
Can you see that?
Yes, you can see it.
I'll try this way.
The red Republicans
and the blue Democrats,
the two Independents--
Sanders and Lieberman.
This was about 2004.
And then the three crossovers
are Specter, Collins and Snow.
And that proved to be
predictive, if you will--
that's a word near and dear
to Alissa-- but predictive
of the three Republicans
who would vote for Obama's
reconstruction rebuilding plan.
So that's the kind of
data sets we were after.
It's still available
in a free version,
but also a paid version.
And currently EventFlow,
and that's tomorrow's talk,
is about for looking at
electronic health records.
If you have a million
patients and you
want to look at the common
patterns of treatments
and outcomes, this is the
way we hope you'll do it.
So take a look.
And Megan Monroe is
one of the key workers
on developing EventFlow into
the powerful tool that it is.
Take a look at her videos
on the EventFlow web site.
My favorite one is the one about
her analysis of a basketball
game, of every shot
and pass turnover.
And she captures in a
charming and brilliant way
how the game turned out
in a way that was not
visible from other statistics.
So this talk is about big data.
OK?
And big data is often described
as a flood, as a torrent,
as a tidal wave that's
drowning in data.
All these negative views of the
way data is overwhelming us.
For me though, data
is really good.
It's the sweet
irrigation from which
we will forge the new ideas that
we need to make our world still
better.
So I'm here to
change the metaphors
and to push us down a
positive road that says
big data is great opportunity.
And now we have to figure
out how to put it to work--
how to put it to work
responsibly and safely.
And those are going
to be the key themes.
So I go back to the
original big data initiative
that Obama launched.
It's now 2012--
so six years ago.
In this three page
White House announcement
there were two challenges--
developing scalable algorithms
for processing imperfect data
in distributed data spores.
Quite nice.
That's the machine learning
and algorithmic approach
and doing all those things.
However, number two
or equally the other
challenge-- creating effective
human computer interaction
tools.
Pretty good.
I had some influence
on this document
so my words get in there, too.
For facilitating
rapidly customizable--
and I like this
phrase, this was not
mine-- but visual reasoning
for diverse missions.
So I want to remind
you that while we
may be talking about
technology solutions here,
we also have to at the same
time talk about human solutions.
That's where we're going.
The White House repeated
the big data strategies
a couple of years ago.
There's too much to
read here, but I want
to focus on one piece of this--
support R&D trustworthiness
of data and the resulting
decisions.
OK?
And they use this
phrasing, which I like--
to promote transparency,
including tools--
they got it again--
that provide detailed audits--
I like that-- to show the steps
that led to a specific action.
OK?
It's pretty clear and
straightforward about what
the White House was asking
for in terms of building
the right kinds of technology.
Now I had addressed this issue,
and again thanks to Alyssa
for mentioning the book.
Originally in 1986,
in there, there
was a section, which was titled
"Balancing Automation and Human
Control".
And it was built on Tom
Sheridan, MIT researcher who
had cataloged 10 levels of the
movement from human control
to full automation that
had machine control.
And that vision has
remained the stable part.
It's changed in some ways.
In fact in the
driverless car world
there are five levels
of automation now.
And so that way of thinking
continues to dominate.
However, I began to
diverge from that.
And I just didn't like
the idea of partnership--
of working together
or a balance.
So in the sixth
edition, that section--
you can read that and
get the full story.
It says ensuring human control
while increasing automation.
Now that may sound like a bit
of a mystery, like a [INAUDIBLE]
on some kind that you
need to meditate on.
But that's where I've come
to stand quite strongly.
I think we're going
you want to be
clearer and clearer that
the humans are in control
and therefore the word
responsibility will
come into play.
And the way we get
it is by getting
increased, but the right
kinds, of automation.
OK.
So that's where
we're going to go.
Now these ideas have some merit.
And I just want to remind
you that the notions of user
control--
and thank you for mentioning
that was originally
in my list--
but Apple and the
Microsoft guidelines
still say the same thing.
That they stipulate-- this is
Apple design for their products
and the iOS apps-- people,
not apps, are in control.
OK?
Flexibility-- whoops.
Come back here.
Flexibility-- users
complete-- flexibility--
the users complete fine-grained
control over their work.
OK?
That's also a pretty
clear statement.
So this is quite at odds
what you see, and much
of the literature and
descriptions about AI
and machine learnings and
machines are taking our jobs
and the rise of the robots
in a variety of other ways.
And so that's where I
want to take you here.
I hope to convince
you by the end
that this is a fresh and
important way to think,
and we need to change the
language of discussion
and the way we go about
building new technologies if we
want to build safety.
That's really our goal.
Again there's other people,
other voices that I join with.
Cathy O'Neil's excellent book,
"Weapons of Math Destruction",
describes the dangers of
opacity, of black boxes,
of when algorithms are used at
scale and they produce damage.
These algorithms slam doors in
the face of millions of people,
often for the flimsiest of
reasons, and offer no appeal.
And she has chapter
after chapter
that talks about how
teachers were fired,
how loan applicants
were rejected,
how prisoners requesting
parole were rejected from that,
and on and on.
Medical applications and so on.
So she has written
this in a very--
she's a Harvard
grad, by the way,
and worked on Wall Street
and PhD mathematician.
But she's written a
wonderfully compelling book
that makes the case.
And her point is
that algorithms can
be biased, harmful and deadly.
OK?
I guess this has become
common knowledge.
I hope everybody in the room
has seen these arguments
and appreciate that
there is tension.
In preparing for
this talk I went out
to captured the covers
from recent reports.
My favorite, if you're going
to read one, is this one--
"Ethically Aligned Design".
This one, I really like.
It's about 200 authors from
20 committees within IEEE.
It presents fresh language,
fresh thinking, practical ways
forward.
That's the one I love.
I wrote a blog for IEEE, a
sort of love letter for them.
The bad guys are over here.
Now this report, which
is a little older now,
does suggest there's nothing
different from people
and machines.
It's just a degree of
the speed of performance.
Human minds and computers
are quite the same.
So I didn't quite like that one.
This is an interesting one that
focuses on malicious use of AI
and forecasting prevention
and mitigation from people
that we all respect like
Electronic Frontier Foundation,
Cambridge and Oxford
Universities, so on,
Open AI Group.
And this one from the world
wide web foundation on algorithm
accountability-- a
nicely written report
that focuses on the web.
And there's more.
This is a recent one--
European Group on ethics in
science and new technologies,
artificial
intelligence, robotics
and autonomous systems.
And this also just
a couple of weeks
ago upturns a Washington
based think tank
and supported by
[INAUDIBLE] Network
and then the New
York based AINOW NYU.
Kate Crawford and
Meredith Whitaker
are key players
in here, but they
follow ideas that are
close to what I'm saying.
And so that's one
I'm sympathetic to,
and it's just
recently released--
practical framework for
public agency accountability.
So this is a topic
that's in the air.
And I enjoyed the discussion
with the Radcliffe Fellows
this afternoon.
And I hope many of you
are aware of these issues.
My pitch is responsibility
is the key to understanding,
and particularly
responsibility for failures.
So that's the model
I'm going to build on,
and there's going to be two
other components to it as well.
Now an important player
for this report--
don't read all this--
but is the two page report from
the USACM, which I'm a member
and I was part of
this committee, which
is the public policy group of
the Association for Computing
Machinery, the main professional
group with 100,000 members.
And they got
together and prepared
this report, which was then
endorsed by the European branch
as well.
And it has seven principles, and
we're going to look at those.
OK?
And I would say
this is a good one.
It's good to read.
It's just a page and a half,
so it's a very readable thing.
And it has seven principles.
My criticism-- and
in the short time
we had to push this
report forward,
I couldn't get the
specificity that I wanted.
But they're on the right track.
So awareness-- owners,
designers, builders and users
of stakeholders should be
aware of the possible biases
and harms.
There actually should
be a zero level rule,
which is the
awareness that there
is a system, an AI
system being used
in some of these environments.
In fact, Nick
Diakopoulos has begun
to collect-- there's
a website which
he lists all government,
as much as he can find,
government systems which have
AI systems built into them,
which have potentials for bias.
So we should be aware that
things are being done,
and then we should be aware of
the possible biases and harms.
But I was critical of shoulds.
When you see shoulds in a
statement-- should be aware--
how do you know if
someone's aware?
And who should be aware?
Who certifies this?
How do you validate that?
Similarly, access and redress.
Regulators should
adopt mechanisms that
enable questioning and redress.
Which regulators?
How do you get a question asked?
What's the redress?
What's going on here?
OK?
A good principle, but
it's a bit high level.
And we need to make
it more specific.
Accountability.
Institutions should
be responsible,
even if it is not
feasible to explain
how algorithms
produce the result.
So who holds them responsible?
And we're well past the time--
and this proposal is a year old.
And I think the movement
has gone well past--
everybody says
yes, this is right.
But now how do we do it?
And so that's really the
substance of discussion
that I hope to contribute to.
Four, explanation--
another hot topic.
Systems and institutions
that use algorithmic decision
making are encouraged--
are encouraged--
oh, sure they're
encouraged to produce
explanations of the procedures
and decisions.
How do they do that?
And when do they do that?
And where do they publish that?
And who can see it?
So I think there's a lot that
needs to be resolved here.
There are industry
committees or government
agencies around
the world and are
pushing towards this happening.
Explanation is a particularly
key issue in Europe.
The GDPR, General
Data Protection Board,
will start on May 25th--
will require that companies
give explanations to people
who feel they've been harmed.
Now it was well-intentioned.
It's a good idea.
I support the GDPR.
However, it was
pretty vague about how
that's going to happen.
So the appearance of that
will change things in Europe,
and I hope eventually
move to this country.
Fifth, data provenance.
Algorithm builders should
maintain a description of how
draining data was collected.
Where do they keep
this information?
Who gets to see it?
Is it open?
We don't quite know.
What's the format
of this information?
We don't yet know.
Again, I repeat, I'm
happy with this report
but there's still work to
be done on any one of these.
If you're working in these
areas and you contribute
to any one of
these seven, you'll
be doing something valuable.
Auditibility-- Models,
algorithms, data and decisions
should be recorded so
they can be audited.
I think you know what
I'm going to say.
I mean, what do
we mean by should?
Where do they get recorded?
What form do they
get recorded in?
Is there a standard way?
Is it a machine readable form?
And what if we
don't like the way
the audit report
has been prepared?
So those are the questions.
Validation and testing.
Institutions should
use rigorous methods
to validate their models.
Which rigorous methods?
How is rigorous enough?
OK?
And I will tell you that while
there are those who say we
don't want to have any
regulations that will limit
innovation-- it's sort of a
current mantra of many people--
the fact is many of the
people in the companies
I speak to actually
want a clear message.
They want to know,
what should I be
doing as a responsible company
in order to do the right thing.
How far do I have to go?
What will make me be seen as
a responsible corporation,
and that when things go bad
the public and the insurance
companies will say you did OK?
And will not fault them
for being insufficient.
So I think the insurance
companies will be our friends
in this domain, as they have
been in many other areas
like the structure of
buildings and housing,
that they'll provide insurance
if you have flood protection,
if you've used the right kind
of construction materials,
and so on.
OK.
So I come back and
just remind you
the sort of mantra I
want to wash over you,
because changing minds is hard.
I just want you to remember,
we want to ensure human control
while increasing automation.
OK.
And my mechanism for
going about doing this
is a well practiced
method, which
we will have to adapt
to new situation
and its independent oversight.
I became involved and
studied 40 different systems
of independent oversight, and
developed a little taxonomy,
which is what I
want to get to here,
and see how then we can apply
this in the case of algorithm
design.
So there are independent
oversight mechanisms.
Every company that registers
with the Securities
and Exchange Commission
must have an internal audit
committee and advisory
boards and external audits.
And we kind of accept that.
There's more than
10,000 companies
which go through this
process every year
and file their reports with
the Securities and Exchange
Commission.
And there are rules about how
these external audits get done.
The big accounting
companies make a good amount
of money on this, but
hopefully they provide value
because they give the
kind of stamp of approval
that says you're
doing the right thing.
And that makes it better
hopefully for all of us.
Now there are certain rules
that have been practiced
over the year that says
look, the external auditor
has the right to see
this and this data
and not to see that data.
There's also criteria
about what happens
to the report of the
external auditor.
It's not very useful if you
have a external auditor writes
a report and nothing happens.
So there's an expectation
that within a year
these companies will follow
up on the recommendations
of that report so that when
next year's report is done
there can be some feedback
and validation that this
is going OK.
All right?
University accreditation,
NSF, and British EPSRC
advisory boards are all other
forms of independent oversight.
And of course, tenure committees
are another form of oversight.
And the right level of
independence in each of these
is important.
For committees there
should be people
who know the discipline
well enough, but not
so close that they're completely
submerged in it, or not
so close.
Same thing when the Federal
Reserve has oversight of banks.
They want people who
know the banking industry
and maybe know the company
fairly well, but not
so close that they're
friends with the people who
are the leaders of the company.
There's rules about subpoena
power and investigation
and reporting and what
can be made public.
So these are all well exercised,
including many of these other
technologically centered
organizations like NASA,
the FAA, Food and
Drug Administration,
Department of Home-- all
of them have some forms
of independent oversight.
And these committees
evolve their strategies
for doing their investigations.
So the National
Transportation Safety Board's
may be the most I think,
respected and effective
of these.
And we all know about them.
And I'm talking about a national
algorithms safety board.
OK?
So the Transportation
Safety Board
did come in for the Tesla
car crash a year ago,
which killed the driver.
And if you read their 60 page
report, it's quite nicely done.
I was quite impressed, actually.
And it describes all
the circumstances
and then has a set of
conclusions and then
recommendations.
Now among their
recommendations was
one that's near and
dear to my heart, which
was careful logging
of what happens.
And it turns out
that Tesla did not
have the kind of logs
that would enable
the outside investigators to
understand what's going on.
OK?
Now the model again, is
the flight safety recorder,
flight data recorder
on airplanes.
When a triple 7
crosses the Atlantic,
there's about a petabyte
of data generated.
And that's a huge
amount of data.
But there's been an
industry agreement about how
to structure that data.
And there are
software tools that
let the analysts
understand what's going on.
And I think the development
of those two strategies
will be one of
the things we want
to see for AI robotic
systems of the future--
that we need to have a careful
logging that's been decided on.
Maybe it's different
from medical devices.
for aircraft.
Maybe it's different for
financial transactions.
Maybe it's different
for business decision
making systems.
And there'll be
increasing levels of care
when we moved from discretionary
systems, lightweight things
like recommenders,
to consequential
things like mortgage financing,
hiring of teachers, parole
and so on or financial
trading, and then things that
are life critical applications
like transportation,
medical devices and so on.
So we're going to need to get
more nuanced in understanding
what to capture in
each of these cases.
And while the NTSB
does it fine, I
think, because of
their experience
with the Tesla crash and the
recent Uber pedestrian death--
they're still investigating
that of course.
I think broadening it out to
algorithm safety board would
get a cadre of investigators
who come to know what to look
for when disaster occurs.
So I'm proposing three
kinds of oversight.
And the first one is
planning oversight.
That's in advance.
If you're going to launch
a robotic or AI system,
and then like a zoning
board where you come forward
and you say I want
to build a house,
and here's my plan for building
this house or this store
or office building--
and the zoning board reviews
this and then gives you
approval to go build it.
And then when you're done the
zoning inspector comes back,
checks out that you
did it, and gives you
a certificate of occupancy.
And over time that process
of discussion in advance
leads to a wise set of
guidelines about fire rules,
that you can't use
asbestos, that you
have to use certain kind
of construction materials,
you need structurally
strong, depending
if you may need a two story
or a 12 story building.
And all those things
become open discussions
where everybody knows
what the code is
and what the code will be
for these robotic systems
will emerge.
Again, I think
industry specific.
And I think that's a nice
kind of adversarial approach
where people discuss--
someone says,
I want to build this building.
And someone may say well,
we're your neighbors.
And we don't think you
should build this building
because it's going to cause
subsidence or floods or so on.
It's going to block the
light of our building.
Or others who say we're
speaking for the fire department
and we just can't feel that
we can have our fire fighters
go into this building
because it's not
built according to the
strength and safety we want.
Or these days, earthquake
resistance, flood resistance
or other issues.
And we'll come to
understand where
the dangers are in different
biases of machine learning
systems.
Second approach-- and this
is the more expensive one--
so I'm less pushing on this one.
But this is the
Federal Reserve Board.
And they do
continuous monitoring
as does the Food and
Drug Administration
for pharmaceuticals
and meat packing
and food packing
and distribution
and other circuits.
These require someone to be
there and watch what's going on
and ask the right questions
and keep it going.
OK?
So continuous
monitoring is expensive
and it results in things
like the Federal Reserve
coming one day and saying
looks like you denied loans
to 27 black women yesterday.
What's going on?
And is there a reason for it?
And then the bank says you
know, we had no idea about that.
Why did that happen?
Let's go check it out.
We don't want to do that.
And so the monitors can be
an asset for the companies,
as well.
Doesn't always work
as wonderfully,
and sometimes things go
bad even with monitors.
But the evidence is very
strong that this kind
of continuous monitoring
is very effective.
Again, very expensive
but very effect.
The third is probably
the clearest case,
is the retrospective
analysis idea.
When something bad goes on--
when a Tesla car kills somebody
or Uber runs over a pedestrian--
somebody shows up who
knows how to investigate
and has access to the data.
And this again, has
to be independent.
It can't be that Tesla or
Uber say we'll check it out.
We'll do our own study.
No.
I mean, I'm advocating the idea
that independent oversight has
value and you want to
create a certain tension.
And you want to
develop the strategies
by which the
analysts can come in
and where the
company says no, you
can't have that part of our--
that's our protected
company information.
But you can have
this information.
That's what we've all agreed to.
So here's my little model of it.
And this really gets
me to most of what
I want to accomplish here--
the idea that there
are social strategies
that can produce the kind
of technical solutions.
Now the technical solutions,
I've suggested already.
The first thing I
want is appropriate
monitoring and logging
of what happens.
OK?
The second thing I want
is a proper modular design
of algorithms so that analysts
can understand what's going on.
I would say the model for
this is debugging tools, where
you don't just print
out everything,
but you have certain
breakpoints in the program.
The program is
modularly designed
so that you can track where
the problem is and you
can say with authority--
you can say with
authority we fixed it.
That problem won't happen again.
OK?
And that's how I think
airline systems have become
such safe and good
models of what
we want to build for
manufacturing robotic systems.
Apparently there are 33 deaths
by robot manufacturing systems
in the US.
And from what I understand,
only two of them
are fully understood
as to what went wrong.
And that seems
frightening to me.
So I'm here to raise awareness
and promote an approach, which
will provide the social,
political, or maybe
legal mechanisms that will drive
the right technical solutions.
OK?
And these issues about
degree of independence,
subpoena power I
mentioned, and the power
to enforce
recommendations-- now,
you can get my short
paper about this
in the proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences,
from which this figure is taken.
So I come back
one more time here
to say ensuring human
control while increasing
the level of automation.
We have many ways in which we
have highly automated systems,
but we feel in control.
When you step into an
elevator and you press seven,
the light goes on that says
you're going to seventh floor.
And you see are on
the third floor now,
and you get to
the seventh floor.
And the systems are
comprehensible at the level
you want.
They are predictable.
You press seven, you get
to the seventh floor.
And they're comprehensible,
predictable and controllable.
OK?
You can get where
you want to get.
Now they're not
completely in control.
Is there a limitation
of what you can do?
But within the cognitive model
of the users of an elevator
they have a sense of
comprehensible, predictable and
controllable.
And sometimes you see new
elevators, which don't quite
have all these features.
There are ones that don't
display the floor you're on
or you're going to.
They're kind of scary and
you feel out of control.
And I would say this
is the phenomena that
happens with
airplanes, which have
excessive degrees of
automation in the auto pilot.
The multiple modes
that the planes
can be in confuse the
pilots and the stories
that I've read carefully
one after another
are kind of frightening,
that the heading of the plane
is not shown in a apparent way.
The state of them the
autopilot does not
show that it's in
landing mode two and then
switches to aborting
the landing.
In one Airbus crash
in Thailand, the plane
decided it was going to
abort and began to turn out.
The pilot pushed the
stick to go further down.
The plane turned
to go further up.
The pilot pushed the
stick to go down.
The plane went
further up, stalled,
and everyone was killed.
OK?
Completely unnecessary
kind of outcome.
If the engineers
and designers had
been more thoughtful
about giving information
and gave the status
to the pilots,
they might have avoided that.
So the solution that I advocate
is National Algorithm Safety
Board, and I just close by--
and happy to have questions--
to design for safety the goal
is to clarify responsibility.
It's especially clear in
clarifying responsibility
for failures.
And my approaches are
independent oversight
where there's open and
adversarial reviews,
transparency-- it
opens the black box,
accountability for open failure
reporting and liability.
So currently many systems
have hold harmless contracts.
Medical systems, for example,
that in most software systems
the authors of
those software tools
do not accept responsibility.
They say software is a
difficult and unpredictable art,
and if the software
has a bug or goes wrong
we take no no
responsibility for it.
That's kind of an
adolescent approach.
And I think it's time
to move the computing
field beyond its
adolescent stage
and for it to accept serious
forms of responsibility.
So I close with-- you may
have you may have seen this
television commercial,
hotel Trivago--
this paired associate,
hotel with Trivago.
So what I want you to
take away from this
is safety, responsibility,
safety, responsibility, safety,
responsibility.
Those are the ways I
think we'll get it.
If you want safety,
which I think we all do,
then you're going
to have to address
the fact of responsibility.
And it troubles me
that in many situations
that is unresolved-- especially
the driverless car situation.
Who pays for damages?
And I think the
early clarification
of that will
accelerate the movement
towards driverless cars, which
I see as a virtuous possibility.
And I want to see it happen.
I want to see it happen in a
responsible and positive way.
So there we are again--
safety, responsibility.
OK, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you so much, Ben.
So we have time for questions
and we can get started.
We have people with
microphones, so
if you would just
put your hand way
up so they can see you and--
gentlemen the
yellow jacket there?
- It seems that you assume that
you can derive an explanation
either by building
a system that's
going to have
explanation built into it
or that you can do the
forensics after the fact.
But it seems that we're
at a point in design
based on large amounts of data
where you will no longer be
able to do the forensics.
Why did the driverless car not
interpret the bicycle walking
route across the street?
And so I think there's a
problem with the assumption
that you'll be able to do
the NTSB kind of analysis.
And I think you're going to
have to go to a direction
where there's going to
be a authority who'll
validate an algorithm, held
out data, cross validated
and certified in some way.
Because I don't know how you'll
do the forensics when there's
a black box with 100,000
parameters and some machine
learning system that says
the answer was black.
- I would say if it's
that much out of control,
if it's that poorly
designed, shut it down.
OK?
Now I know the counter
is, well would you rather
have a safe system or one that
you have an explanation that's
not as safe?
I don't think that's a choice.
I think the choice is to
get a safe system, which
is explainable.
I think the engineers
are up to it.
My optimism is guided by
the FAT ML conference--
fair, accountable and
transparent machine
learning-- four years
of pretty interesting
work in that community.
I'm encouraged by the DRPA
XAI, Explainable AI program.
I think what we
need to point out
is that the past history
of some workers in AI
have been driven by
game-like applications,
whether it's go or chess
or other kinds of things,
or things that were
not consequential.
OK?
They're valuable-- natural
language translation,
speech recognition.
But when we move towards
consequential things
I think we should have higher
expectations from the engineers
who built these systems.
I think that's
where we're going.
If they want to be
contributors to these important
consequential
applications they've
got to get their act
together or shut them down.
- And some sort of
government certification
that these driverless cars--
- Well, I was not too pushing
hard about government.
These days a government
certification--
there is I repeat
strong industry support.
The partnership for AI is the
leading five top companies
who are pushing for some
form that will develop,
that would give them
the assurance they're
doing the right thing.
And I would say
I don't buy this.
And I get angry-- excuse
me-- of the argument
from some of the AI community.
100,000 features, parameters,
100 level neural networks.
How can I possibly explain it?
If you can't have a way of
saying on the next time when
I see the same data I'm going
to get it right, shut it down.
I mean, I think that
would be the test.
If when something goes bad and
you've captured the log of what
happened, fix the program.
Replay it and show me that the
same thing does not reoccur.
OK?
I think that's the kind of test.
Thank you.
- We have a question over here.
- OK.
Yeah.
- Hi.
I think my question is
actually thematically
similar to the
previous question.
But for your recommended
interventions
here for governance, you lean
on different mental models
of regulation and oversight like
monitoring and data sharing,
like post-hoc
analysis and so on.
Do you think the issue of
algorithmic accountability
can be regulated
using these existing
mental models for this
kind of monitoring,
or do we need new ones?
In part because of phenomena
like complex interactions
and like the difficulty
with getting input A,
output B every single
time in these systems?
Do we need a mental
model that accommodates
fuzzier kinds of outputs or
a probabilistic reasoning
or something that looks
at interaction effects?
- I'm getting closer
to what you want.
I'm not sure exactly what
you're meaning by mental models.
But I think mental models are
a useful way to describe it.
My mental model in an elevator
is I press the seventh floor
and it gets me there.
I don't understand
all that's going on,
but I trust that there's
a reliable system that
will get me there.
I also see in the
elevator that it
has an inspection certificate--
that someone's checked to see
that this elevator functions
as promised.
I don't expect every
consumer or citizen
to be completely
knowledgeable about it.
But I think the mechanisms by
which various intermediaries,
consumer groups, public
interest groups and so on
can act in that way.
There's a role for
Underwriters Laboratory,
for Consumer Reports, for
better Business Bureau--
all these traditional
groups that helped
accelerate commerce
by building trust.
We need to invoke them
in new ways, maybe.
And they will guide us, I
think, to get the right idea.
I think, again, some
of the AI people
say the only way to
control AI is of more AI.
And I don't agree.
I think the only
way to control AI
is to have a social mechanism,
a political mechanism by which
there is an open discussion
and which failures
can be investigated openly.
All right?
Thank you.
- So over here.
- Yes, thank you.
- Thank you.
So safety and responsibility
true to shared logging,
and then also better
tools for the analysts.
Right?
- Yes.
- My question is related
to especially thinking
about autonomous vehicles.
What is a model to incorporate
the community level
knowledge that is needed?
Because I would imagine
the driving behavior
should be different in
different parts of the world
and different neighborhoods.
So what is the framework to
incorporate community data
in a way like this
kind of local knowledge
that maybe doesn't come
from the analysts or NTSB?
- I mean, this is discussed in
the driverless community, that
may be different cultures,
different countries
will actually have different
forms of regulation,
different values or
ethics introduced there.
I think the model for that would
be the local planning boards.
The local planning boards
have some decision making.
Now, you want to have
automation at every local point,
but maybe at the
state level in the US.
And again, maybe
at industry level
would be another way
to partition the space.
Then I think you might have
a planning or oversight
board based on medical devices.
And the experts in
that field, which
some of what FDA does
already, would be
the ones that you would invoke.
Just as for the
Transportation Safety Board,
you have that for
automobiles, ships and trains.
So I think there's
examples to build.
And again, it's just to open--
it was a challenge
for me to open my mind
and to think outside
the technology solutions
and to think about
how you can create
the right incentives that will
build the right technology
solutions.
I see the other hands.
Yeah.
- Oh, wait.
We have a question over here.
- Yes.
- Thank you.
- Two questions are
somewhat related.
So first, a practical one.
That you say there
is a planning phase,
but when do you envision
this planning phase?
Because you don't want to shut
down innovation in a research
setting.
And so I was
thinking, for example,
for drug discovery there
is a clinical trial phase.
Could there be some
kind of testing phase--
- Absolutely.
- --is based on evidence?
I hope I made clear,
research should proceed.
You don't need to have a
review document for research,
and for many things
you should be able to.
It's only when--
Kathy O'Neil-- when
you're at scale.
When you're going to field--
if a major bank
with 3,000 branches
is going to install a new
system for allocating loans,
that's the moment.
And they had planning documents.
They planned to do that for
whatever-- a year or two years.
And at some point
during that process,
just as they would if they
were going to build a building,
they would have to
go for permission.
And I think we
should come to see
the construction of major
scalable and consequential
tools that should have a
review process, whatever-- six
months in advance
of implementation
and then a review process before
the button to launch it goes.
And the development
also, we didn't
talk about the set
of test cases that
would verify or help validate.
It was part of the USACM list.
But there would be an
agreement that these
are the 27, or 2,700 test
cases that we should run
before your algorithm can go.
- So a follow up question--
during these test cases
or the planning phase--
so in the cases that
you focus on safety
I see more clear there
could be a yes or no answer.
But there are some
parts of AI that
are much more
subtle, maybe that's
related to these mental models.
But for example, if
you apply an algorithm
to help guide how
do you do education,
or something that in part
could be much farther than--
I mean, there is
not a safety risk,
an immediate risk that you'll
get from the algorithm.
But there might be an
impact in society over time.
- Sure.
- How do you evaluate those?
- You're right.
I mean, there will
be subtle cases
where you're saying the
impact could be far off.
You have a AI system
that grades your homework
and you fail a course, and
the consequences are quite far
but the algorithm was mistaken.
OK?
We had the recent case
of the FMRI data--
40,000 papers, I think
it was, were invalid
because the algorithm in the
FMRI system was incorrect.
OK?
And those things happen.
So we have actual
bugs in systems,
but we have poorly
designed systems as well.
And I think we need to develop
strategies to make that happen.
Yeah.
- The case for better controls
on important systems certainly
is a strong one.
But I think we should
see it as an opportunity
and be more optimistic that
the automated systems are
more, not less susceptible
to the controls.
What are the controls over
unfettered human discretion
in mortgages?
What is the
reconstruction mechanism
for why a human
driver had a crash?
- Yes.
- So I think it's a very
positive kind of thing,
that as our systems are more
and more knowledge based,
they're better able
to be inspected.
Human based systems are
not very inspect able.
- That's a little
harsh, I would say.
Accidents are investigated
where humans are part of,
and loans and
banks are monitored
by the Federal Reserve.
Now, you don't believe that.
- I don't believe
it [INAUDIBLE]..
- It may be ineffective.
It may fail at times.
So maybe we need to way
to strengthen those.
But I do think there's the
need to integrate a higher
level and not technical--
that's beyond the developers.
When the developers say trust
me it's going to be fine,
don't win the day with me.
OK?
If they want to present
it to others and say
I've adhered to
these 27 guidelines
and here is the system
that's out there.
We're going to have a pilot
trial for three months.
We'll validate it during that
just as any new aircraft.
New aircraft-- there's
a good example--
gets certified by the FAA.
OK?
There's a testing process
by which it's certified.
And then they get
a certificate that
allows them to sell
and have passengers
travel on those planes.
And I think we can
find those mechanisms.
They will be imperfect.
I know that.
Current human systems
are imperfect.
We're always striving
to be better.
I think that's also
something-- somehow
the AI and often the tech
community and computer
science and my colleagues
assume the world can
be made in a fully rational
way, and that everything
can be algorithmic,
and that if we
had only more rational discourse
that everything would be fine.
But life is a little
more complicated,
I would like to say.
And so I think we
have to deal honestly
with the complexities
of real life.
- Go ahead.
Did you have a question?
- Another question?
- OK.
Oh, lots of hands.
Thank you.
- Hi.
Good afternoon.
Thank you for this good talk.
So my questions maybe touch on
a couple things you just said.
I'm curious about
what your thoughts are
on the culture of programming
and where that might go.
I mean, we're here at
a teaching institution.
My own experience
with programming
is that the culture tends
to be fairly Wild West.
- Fairly what?
- Wild West--
- Wild West, OK.
- --in terms of standards
and also just how it goes.
And part of that question
there is really about
how we do with complexity
and hyper-specialization.
And then separate
from that maybe is I'm
wondering what your thoughts
are around feedback loops.
As these AI algorithms become
more complex the feedback
loop into how society works
becomes more profound, I think.
- Yeah.
Those are rather larger
things, I would say.
The Wild West nature of
the programming community
has been faulted by
on many occasions
and I don't think I want
to go to far with that.
But I think Wild West
is a safe enough one.
But the many problems--
I think the culture
of programming--
I think courses in ethics in
programming should be required.
I think they're part of
the required curriculum,
but many universities don't
include such a course.
The ACM has a code of ethics
currently being revised,
and that's another
good source to look at.
So there are ways
we could make--
and as I say, it's an
adolescent culture maybe,
is another way to
say it, which I'm
looking for it to see maturity.
And maturity means taking
responsibility for what you do.
And there may be things like
those hold harmless clauses
that I think could be changed.
And that when companies
take responsibility,
I believe good things-- more
good things will happen.
And your second point was--
- The feedback loops.
- The feedback loop.
Yeah.
I mean, yes.
I'm not sure that's
controversial.
- The challenge
there is how do we
know when the perspective,
our perspective--
how do we know when
our perspective has
shifted to a point where--
- Who is the our?
- Societal perspective.
Right?
So if we're looking at
keeping track of algorithms
and saying well, this algorithm
isn't behaving correctly--
but that's our
subjective opinion
and that's subject to change,
but is also subject to--
- You raise another issue
which came up earlier
in the day, of the
role that we might
have as academics in
creating public discourse
and informativeness about this.
And I think that's
a valuable thing.
I have sort of struggled
with the battle
of the rise of the
robots, the robots
are going to take our
jobs away, there's going
to be widespread unemployment.
I think that's preposterous.
I just think that's a
failed understanding
of the nature of technology.
I see the effect of
technology is producing
what I call techno-genesis.
That is new
technologies generate
a lot more than they destroy.
Yes Gutenberg's presses put
the scribes out of work.
You want to count how
many unemployed scribes?
OK, we can count those.
But it created a worldwide
literacy, a readership,
publishing industry,
and most importantly
it amplified the potential
for creativity of writing.
Writing was not
a common process.
People did not write books.
And every technology--
whether photos, photography--
1939 Louis Daguerre
makes photography.
The French painter
Delaroche says from today,
painting is dead.
Well, I don't think
he got that right.
And photography opens up a
world where now everybody
has 100 selfies on their phone
and everybody's a photographer.
You create a world
of opportunity.
Gramophones, music players,
iPods and your phones.
OK?
Did that wipe out the
performance of music?
No.
Did it change it
and challenge it?
Yes.
OK?
I really wonder--
are there more people
making music and composing music
than there were 100 years ago?
Kind of an interesting question.
I tried to find that number.
If anyone can help me with
that, I'd love to see it.
But I would say
that technologies,
which would seem to wipe out
the jobs of a certain category,
create technogenesis.
They generate huge industries.
Similarly, I mean
I've got about 20
of these I've been writing down.
I think you get the idea.
I'll give you more
if you want them.
- We have like,
three more questions.
We have one, two and three.
- So I wanted to ask--
I love to talk about
accountability of algorithms.
But I ask about the
partner of algorithms.
So algorithms are pretty
innocuous by themselves.
It's the data that
gets them into trouble.
So I'm wondering what you think
about data accountability?
The data that forms the
algorithms and the data that
algorithms operate on.
- Thank you.
Yeah, absolutely.
I run into this because I'm
a proponent of visualization
tools.
And I might say take a look
at Fernando Viagens' work
at Google and use
the visualization
to understand machine
learning and neural networks.
And it's a whole
effort at Google
that's been transformational--
another one of those that
encouraged me to
believe that you could
have these kind of things.
So the data though,
has a few problems.
The one I run into most
is the data is poor.
The quality of the data--
it's incomplete,
it's contradictory.
There's all kinds of things.
I could tell you
lots of stories where
the visualization tools that
we developed revealed problems.
6,300 emergency room
admissions and they're
asking the average
age of the men
and the women and
those discharged.
And they had no
idea after running
all kinds of stats--
simple stats,
not machine learning--
but they had
no idea that eight of those
patients were 999 years old.
Kind of a simple thing
to miss, isn't it?
They had no idea that about 60
of were under one years old--
a very unusually large number.
And that was because in
part of the hospital the way
they enter the
age of the patient
was they enter the birth year.
And they made consistent errors
of entering the current year.
So you get lots of
patients under one-year-old
who have heart attacks.
OK?
This goes on, of
duplicated data.
A year worth of sales data--
they're making a predictive
model to plan the next year.
They had no idea that
April was missing.
All the spring sales of April
were not in this data set.
For me, the first problem is the
data quality and completeness,
and so on.
I could go on with stories.
But the other part is the bias.
And here I would say
the technical progress
has been the most strong.
The FAT ML community, I think
has done a fair job of looking
at what would be biasing
data for particular--
so loan applications, since we
have legal restrictions on bias
for gender and age and race and
so on, we know that there are
certain--
you don't want to have
those fields in the data.
And then proxies such as zip
code may be a problem, as well.
And these will be specific
to particular industries.
And so I think
that probably shows
opportunities for fairness.
There will always
be emergent bias.
Helen Nissenbaum and
Dr. Friedman long ago
wrote a very thoughtful paper
about the different kinds
of bias.
So that gives us a model
about what to look for
and how the context changes.
What wasn't biased
three years ago now
is biased because of some
change in the context.
And that's part of what went
wrong with the Google Flu
Trends-- another dream of
AI way of predicting where
flu outbreaks would be greatest
in the US by the search queries
that people searched on of
flu or tissues or other things
or medications.
And it turned out that went so
bad that Apple shut that down
and that website is gone.
- Google.
I'm sorry.
Google.
Thank you.
So Google shut that down.
There's a wonderful three
page paper from 2013
in AAAS Science by David Lazer.
He's the first author--
L-A-Z-E-R-- who has a wonderful
analysis of what went wrong.
I think studying the things that
have gone wrong with algorithms
will help us a lot.
Yeah.
I think you said two more.
- David?
- Yeah.
So I wanted.
To start by thanking
you for being here
and for leading this
discourse I think
you can tell from how
animated everybody is
that you've really engaged us.
So thank you for that.
And I also want
to agree with you
that I think the retrospective
is the easiest one.
I think that one, that
makes complete sense to me.
I do want to express some
skepticism about the planning
committee viewpoints.
And also, if I may make a quick
comment about deep learning,
as well.
I really resonate with the
point that [INAUDIBLE] made,
which is that I think that
a different way to say it
is that a planning
commission for a building
has a much easier
task ahead of it
than a planning commission for
a computer technical system.
The proximate concerns in
regards to a building, I think,
are perhaps easier
to understand.
You described it.
Is the light of the building
falling on my neighbor?
Is the building environmentally
appropriately built?
Is the energy system safe?
The proximate kind of
potential side effects
of an AI, algorithmic
system, especially
as AI begins to
essentially do everything--
it seems to me that
your planning board
would have to form a viewpoint
on what's right for society
and what's not
right for society.
So I wanted to make that comment
and invite you to respond.
- Yeah.
Let's--
- You want to take
that one first?
- Let's stay with
one piece at a time.
Yeah.
And I'm happy to engage.
I know some people have
to leave, so thank you.
But well, I don't know.
I've looked at only a little
bit of building codes.
But they're pretty complicated.
So I don't think it's as simple.
We've had 100 years of
experience in developing them,
and so maybe they seem apparent.
I don't think that it should
be so impossible to build
a set of codes, or rules for the
way AI systems should be built.
And I think we're
going to get there.
And I think we should
value and respect
the AI researchers and
engineering communities,
that they can do this.
We just have to set
the public expectation,
they should do this.
OK?
And you made one
passing comment there--
as AI systems get
into everything.
I don't know about that.
I don't think AI systems are as
prevalent as the hype suggests.
When I do email I'm
not using much AI.
A good design of systems
and screens and web sites
are really what drive things.
You begin to see AI.
Recommender systems
are there and we
have other-- machine
translation, natural language
translation.
But I would say AI is a
small part of the world.
To me, the larger issue
is the design of systems
and of the user interface.
So I think we should
be clear that AI is not
so pervasive as is
said, and we should be
careful about what we call AI.
There's a lot of language
now where suddenly everything
is AI.
Every algorithm is
an AI algorithm.
I don't see it that way.
OK?
So we ought to get better
about these clarifications.
OK.
- OK.
I think there's one
to debate there.
But definitely it's an
inflection point where
AI will be doing more and more.
And also, we are
also in a situation
where a lot of things
that have been AI
are no longer
thought about as AI.
So that goes in the
other direction, as well.
Let me get to my second point.
That pause at a automated
vehicle system that
is using a black box, deep
learning technology, and that
through its deployment saves
hundreds, maybe hundreds
of thousands or more lives.
And yet now and again, it just
something really, really stupid
and it kills somebody in a way
that a human would never do.
And again, this is
a black box system.
This is a deep net.
This is a system that you said
that you would shut it down.
Would you shut that system down?
- All right.
So I'll give you an example.
Let's see if we can--
airbags.
The early deployments
of airbags--
is airbag system
deployment AI or not?
- I tossed the microphone.
I would say probably not.
- Probably not, OK.
But it's an algorithm.
That's why I chose to
focus on algorithms,
not particularly not only AI.
Early airbag
systems, the estimate
was it saved about
2,500 lives a year.
On the other hand, the,
early airbag systems
killed about 100 kids--
mostly in the passenger
seat-- a year, inadvertently.
Because their bags
were triggered
and the explosive
force of the airbag
was such that it
killed the child.
OK?
That should have been avoidable.
That should have been something
that was taken into account.
The engineers did
not get it together
to anticipate that problem.
Now OK, maybe I'm
being harsh on them.
But there was a fix.
And so you have to
fix that detects
whether the passenger is
seated, and you can control
the air bag a little better.
You can't control
everything about the airbag,
and because the rapid deployment
in 200 milliseconds means
it has to be an automated
system, but I can control it.
So I feel safe about
putting my child there.
And I know that I put my
child in a rear facing seat.
So we come to learn how
to build those systems.
And I think making the AI
community aware of the dangers
there will lead them
to a path will be more
responsible in taking care.
And then the feedback
that you asked for--
I mean, good news that the
Highway Transportation Safety
Board was collecting the
evidence about inadvertent air
bag deployments that killed.
If we didn't have that feedback,
then we'd never get that fix.
And so this mindless approach
that says don't bother me,
I'm just doing it.
My system will be great.
Everything will be safe--
doesn't work.
And again, another positive
thing-- the airline safety
record is exceptional.
And I think that's due to
the kind of feedback systems
that are built in, and
responsible engineering.
- All right.
- We have one more?
- One last question.
I'm sorry to those of
you in the back who--
you can come talk
to Ben afterwards.
Sir?
- Thanks for a great talk.
The most widely used system that
probably bear no responsibility
is Google Maps.
What changes would
Google Maps need
to make so that it avoids
doing things like accidentally
sending people into fires
in Southern California,
to cite one recent example.
Is it that it needs to be
like, by the way, if you
see a fire don't keep driving.
What fundamental changes would
it need to make to avoid that?
- Well, let's go back here.
I'm still resonating
over your question.
Is Google Maps an AI system?
- It currently has AI.
- It does?
How so?
- Because it takes a
large amount of data--
- Wait one second.
Sorry.
- Sorry.
Well, to cite that
example, it sees
how cars are moving in Southern
California along the highways.
It sees that it doesn't see any
traffic along say, the five.
And it says oh,
go take the five.
That'll get you home fastest.
And then people get
on the five and they
realize there are
no cars on the five
because it turns out
there's a big fire.
That would be one example.
- And that's AI?
- I would argue that that is AI.
- How do you know when it's AI?
You touched on this also.
I mean, Google Maps, as it
started, did not have AI.
It was very good
routing algorithms,
and that's how it worked.
Now it's come along with
some more refined points,
that it amazingly integrates
current traffic data to give
more refined judgment.
But I'm not sure I would
give it the notion it's AI.
You alluded to get the idea
that once AI systems get
mature they don't
call it AI anymore.
Well, I would say
I have another,
maybe more cynical view.
I'll risk it.
Actually, they were
trying AI methods
but the methods didn't work.
And they cleaned them up and
they did good engineering.
And it was clear,
comprehensible and predictable,
and then it worked.
So it's no longer an AI system,
because it is no longer--
It was no longer
called an AI system
because it's not an AI system.
- Wow.
OK.
And on that very
uncontroversial note,
let's just thank Ben again.
- Thank you!
[APPLAUSE]